gianfranco ferré a réussi une entrée
fracassante pour la maison dior dans la
couture française le 27e dé d'or a été
décernée au nouveau directeur artistique
de la maison de l'avenue montaigne 13
voix contre 8 à paco rabanne nouvelle
évocation des collections automne-hiver
89 90 avec marie-josée le picard et
bernard connor nous partons à la
recherche de l'inspiration des
couturiers où trouve-t-il lundi des
questions classiques lorsqu'on regarde
les collections des grands couturiers
cette saison pour gérard qui par le
modéliste de nina ricci l'influencé
clair il avait très envie depuis un
moment de retrouver dans ma tête ce que
poiret a fait dans les années 1910 c'est
à dire une rupture avec tout ce côté
très corsetée habitable et puis en
regardant les collections de tissus au
mois de mai va c'était là c'était dans
les tissus
soares c'est aussi le fourreau à charles
louis guy laroche et sa mariée en
tunique cerceau
chez chanel vient du début de siècle où
la mode de la sécession inspire
peut-être cette régate et chez christian
lacroix les épaules tombantes même
époque les femmes peintes par gustave
keane ses hôtes forme viennent de
l'illustrateur anglais arthur rackham
quant à gianfranco ferré qui vient de
recevoir le dé d'or pour sa première
collection chez christian dior s'est
clairement dans l'opulence du new look
s'il puis sa référence et c'est
peut-être ce qui a touché les
journalistes